I'm missing her
you know I had the steak pie I had her
and don't even show me that [__]
microwave [__] that doesn't even uh that
doesn't even hold a candle to her you
know
everything makes me think of her
everything makes me think of her man you
eat it vertically [__] dude
let me tell you I got on my knees on
that table and I ate it out vertically
and I was like you know
and conversely you know I think Alina
since she had him you know Mr Fish yeah
yeah I think we've both been falling
asleep you know with others on our mind
you know true
good night good night and I roll over
and I'm just thinking about you're
looking at pictures of that steak oh
that's just pie it's like I missed what
are you looking at nothing nothing